mais chez nous c'est une petite question
encore comme personnalité vient de
poster une photo d'elle en culotte sur
instagram caroline receveur amélie
nooten au bout des allées et je sais
vous habitez les auteurs alors à la fin
régime à votre ami à iéna que oui c'est
mon méchant c'est dégueulasse allez ali
ben ali et françois lehmann is a way
après ce que je ne sais pas ce que
j'allais très jolie brune comme ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas vu c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui et photoshop avec
photoshop besoin de photoshop je sais
pas je sais pas si c'est parce que j'en
ai vu récemment elle est hyper belle en
vrai cette fille elle est vraiment hyper
v ne sont pas tous aussi et elle est
nous les vues récemment ici sur le
plateau n'ont pas d'accord en dehors oui
à une soirée je les croisais soit resté
coi la soirée et c'était une soirée on
veut avoir le nom de la foire il m'avait
plus condensée saper une expo au petit
palais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]